for men men want unlimited access to
unlimited sexuality and if you don't
believe me that is men's that's men's
innate nature
go look at any go look at any perception
of hormones it's your perception of men
that they want to have regardless of
their marital status they want to have
sex with as many women as possible from
a biological evolutionary perspective
that is the case that is men's mating
stress
unlimited access
happily married
i didn't ask you i said your perception
of men is that
men
meaning
the majority of men
who are married who are happily married
and go on a work trip
and are stressed out and they're high
valued men and i heard president talk
about high value men you know they got
all this to worry
if you say well does he deserve to go
and have sex with a girl when he's on
business trip right now right okay so
fine but what i'm saying to you is do
you believe that the majority of men
if given the opportunity will just that
will be there to break their vows and
their their their commitment and and do
you think that they would naturally do
that no i don't but i do think and i can
statistically prove this that men get
addicted to online pornography which is
a huge problem so what they're so what
are they doing they're satisfying
unlimited access to unlimited sexuality
through vicarious means in this case
it's it's online porn i don't know why
men don't do that like you know the
implication here is that oh men men do
it and then cheat all the time a lot of
men don't cheat because they they really
respect that woman next time and that is
not the agreement they've entered into
and they don't want that life and maybe
they have a fantastic [ __ ] sex life
with their wife
and they're satisfied not every guy's i
understand pornography is a problem it's
an addiction it's wrecking men it's also
an interesting indicative of men's
innate natural mating strategy it
is speaking it is in men's best interest
to spread what i'm saying though is what
your innate meeting strategy is
is not necessarily how you live or want
to live your life we are promiscuous by
nature we are monogamous by choice
okay
so when uh you're gonna ask me this
anyway so i'll just get this out of the
way okay so here's the deal i don't
think that from a societal perspective
that that is a healthy good way of like
a should a practice right okay because
first off you're entering into a
contract okay i i am compromising my
mating strategy and you are going to
compromise your mating strategy how do
we do that i'm going to forsake all
others in sickness and in health until
death was part for rich or poor poor
that's why those traditional marriage
vows are what they are so if the [ __ ]
hits the fan you're sticking with me no
matter what okay same thing for you what
am i compromising in that formality of
marriage okay my compromise is this i'm
going to give up all my opportunity
costs to breed and have sex with and
enjoy multiple women because i love you
that much i respect you that much i want
to invest all of my resources territory
and everything else into this one
relationship between you and me the
babies are are the most like i'm
parentally investing in our children i'm
partially investing in you because i
think we have a good life together what
woman what women are doing in that
compromise is they're saying okay i'm
not going to try to look for another guy
who is better than you i'm looking for
the quality i'm looking men are looking
for the quantity okay the compromise is
i'm compromising my aspects of my mating
strategy and you're going to compromise
aspects of yours and we're going to come
together and those are the that's the
contract and that's the agreement until
such time as somebody breaches that we
can do it for god and man we can make it
a religious ceremony we can go down to
the courthouse and do it however it is
okay you're making a contractual
agreement between you and that woman
should you honor your contractual
agreement yes i would deal with the
business partner or anything else so
we're looking at it from ethical terms
but also this is that so you've you've
given up on your your your hunt for
another guy and i've given up on my hunt
for
my my entitlement or whatever they want
to call it as you know to have multiple
women and so that we can focus on
monogamy okay and that's really where
marriage begins across across culturally
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
you